hello hello
h3 podcast live it is monday
february 21st
four days until eldon ring comes out
that's right planning on being sick next
week i'm just kidding same
it's a video game we've been waiting to
play sorry guys
[Applause]
it's not just a video game but it's so
much more more than that we've been
waiting years for this
um
guys welcome we've got such a good show
lots of actually really good topics for
a change
who's uh
bringing oh and brought to you by uh
hellofresh
a quick thank you to hellofresh while
you sort out your 2022 budget think
about this you can save 72 on restaurant
quality meals with hellofresh and you
don't even need to hit the grocery store
get 16 free meals plus three gifts with
code h3tv16
at hellofresh.com
h3tv16
and you can make this
gorgeous
gorgeous burrito
and much much more
also a shout out to uh
this awesome shirt that i love that just
dropped on teddyfresh.com i would rather
go to
hell
than to work
who hasn't had days like that not here
obviously never i would never feel that
way
you go to hell that's right
yeah but but i've had jobs where i did
feel like that
you know but none of you guys feel that
way do you oh never
no not a millionaire i'm the other way
about training but not about work about
training
you did that to yourself bro
that bad how's the training going
are you hating it's good i mean it's
it's it's a lot you're shredded i've
get in there slowly yeah surely what are
you talking about you just posted a
thirst trap with a six-pack why are you
downplaying that
yeah i know i mean i feel a lot better
but uh
i don't know sparring five days a week
is a lot
you have very little free time yeah
yeah that's that sucks right
big time box me [ __ ]
well i hope you at least win your fight
thank you
i'm excited when the fight comes up that
we could all we can place bets and stuff
i want to bet on ab
let's see maybe
good luck with that maybe i didn't say
to win
yeah well you get offended yeah i just
said i don't want to play that no i
won't be offended okay
that's good that'd be some good content
either way
i got big money on him i know he's gonna
win how much you putting on him zach i'm
going to put 500 that he's going to win
wow
that's a true friend right yeah that's
that's believe appreciate you i really
believe actually you know what i'll put
500 on it too i think it then we get
really rooting for you yeah and then
when you lose and you come in we're just
going to be like
you lost us
[Laughter]
now you're really going to have to box
um
at least
some of us should go right i know some
it's in florida
probably well we're gonna be well we
should stream it live or well that's
illegal
you get sued by idubbbz
i was just thinking like well we should
live react to the dang thing
we can't do that it's a pay-per-view
event yeah
um one of us should go yeah leena
lina
she'll be there anyway right
uh yeah well actually she has to work so
she can't go
uh
i'm excited it's gonna be fun guys how's
everyone doing today
good hyped chilling no sleep
no sleep again huh
no sleep ever bro i was up with bruce
all night
mixing a little theodore
i did watch in between i watched the new
episode of euphoria
which was good
and i watched
what else did i watch
you're asking me
attack on titan
oh i didn't watch that oh
[ __ ]
okay who cares
watch this
this girl she's made animations first
before and they're always so good man
all right the one thing i watched i
can't talk about i got a pr i got a
screener for something that was real
interesting
i gotta see
god bless you chuck
thank you
sorry sora this girl is such a talent
she's so incredible check this out thank
you you know what i mean it's like
nobody care nobody's sad for you guys
being not as tall so this is what i mean
nobody cares about us tall boys yeah and
they showed it
it's messed up it's [ __ ] up being
called some [ __ ] it's like some
[ __ ] signing with ryan kavanagh
that's it
what's harvey weinstein's height there's
lots of pictures of them together
good question carving weinstein oh so
harvey weinstein was apparently six foot
okay so if you could so if you google
harvey
weinstein ryan kavanagh this is a really
good experiment
because there there is a lot of images
of them standing next to each other
yeah
actually you know what it looks like
harvey weinstein
that's what
that's what i've been saying bro
does ryan kavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein.com
what the [ __ ] you know that's my website
right
it's so stupid
we made that website to help the public
[Laughter]
this is to help people like you
this is a public service
did you really not know that was our
website no that's so awesome
dude i love her amazing
okay first of all
i am not that small okay i am like a 511
bordering on six foot tall i think it's
more about how big he is uh i like how
you progressively are like shrinking up
the entire thing okay just for the
record
and i did notice by the way um
sorry sora if that is your real name
there my hands are looking pretty dainty
in this as well
which i am just not okay with okay
for the record
that's so good that was such a great
moment from the show yeah
so check her out man uh i guess i'll put
a link in the description sorry sora
though she she's yeah i'll uh i'll add
that right now yeah
yeah she's she's awesome man
this was this was like the big one she
made
of
just because i have bad back when uh
this was a thing eating habit doesn't
mean you can eat licorice for breakfast
i can't wait to see who dies first
i can't wait
stupid so how was your weekend
i never know if you hate or like me like
genuinely
i genuinely don't care about you but
because i'm saying i'm indifferent to
you like i don't think about you outside
of this like i think it's cool because
like oh you have like your own thing
going and everything going so it's cool
we do like this collab but i don't think
about you outside of this ever
i just indifferent
i'm gutted
yeah it's all it's all great
so shouts out um
i'm gonna give a little shout out to her
there the top
a lot to get to man i gotta say i feel
like david dobrik's empire is falling
before our eyes it seems like he got
away with it all
but i'm not sure he did get away with it
the cracks are starting to come through
uh don't worry i'm not throwing it to
you yet maybe
david or jeff whittick as you guys know
who he slammed into an excavator nearly
killing him
and uh ruining vision as i unfollowed
him on instagram
and put out a video on patreon which abe
is currently screening
where he's where he goes mask off mask
off on david maskoff dubrick
so
we're gonna watch that but abs
we actually had to subscribe to um
jeff's patreon twice
so that's 30 bucks so you're welcome
you're very welcome jeff
i got to tell you i feel more and more
bad for jeff as time goes on do you
don't you don't feel those share those
feelings dan
i
i feel mixed about it i mean i do i feel
for him in the sense that i mean his
injury is horrific
and
he apparently
is just had his ninth surgery for it um
so i definitely you know feel some
empathy for having to go through that
um and yeah i mean
over time and
this is this is gonna become clear in
what he says in this video from uh from
what i understand
but it seems like his most egregious uh
things that really pissed me off when
that whole situation was going down was
it an effort to
protect david to help david who i think
he you know genuinely thought was his
friend yeah whether or not that was
misguided which you know i'd love to i'd
love to hear him now
because i wonder if he's willing to be
more upfront about
like that whole night and
and
for example or because he just he really
screwed himself by
by covering for david his story made no
sense
exactly right and
i mean that said
separate from all of that i i don't know
you know that that's the whole excavator
situation that is one thing um the
situation that happened with dom
and his handling of that when he came on
her show now
he was
super [ __ ] up in the aftermath of that
accident when he came on our show and
apparently on a bunch of painkillers and
stuff which could explain some of the
weirder moments that happened in all of
that
um you know you
infamously confronted him with those
photos of placing him in a place that he
was vehemently denying
being at uh i don't know if he was lying
i don't know if he was just confused it
was a long time ago he was on a lot of
drugs
um pharmaceutical drugs
when did all of that go down
it was like two years ago no
at the time we interviewed him
uh
right i mean can you recall every detail
of every shoot that you did two years
ago probably not
i'm not trying to excuse it what i'm
trying to actually say is is separating
those two
ins you know i can feel sympathy for
what happened to him with the excavator
but still hold him well that's what i
i'm saying there's still a path to
redemption for jeff
because as he's br he's in a cult as he
breaks from the cult he can be honest
about the stuff he was involved in right
right you know
yeah
well anyway we're currently in his cameo
this we've gotten we've just bought our
fifth uh membership because av keeps
getting logged out
amy bought it one time
and then he got a new phone so he
apparently doesn't have service on it
yet and he wasn't able to get the
confirmation so we bought it on another
membership
and that one is currently working but
standby for to get logged out what phone
did you get
i got the 13 promax
is that the one with like eight cameras
oh wait no that's the samsung actually
isn't it oh that's not the iphone no
it's an iphone iphone 13 pro yeah why
did a new iphone just came out i know
it's been out for a while but verizon
said if i come back they'll basically
give it to me for free and lena's been
wanting new phones so i gave her my
phone and took this
verizon got you uh yep
have you seen
this new samsung phone
it's getting it's getting out of control
that's five that's six little
dots
why does it have so many cameras i don't
know
i mean it's probably they're probably
pretty good at least but yeah it's just
it's starting to look it's starting to
look like that tryptophobia
exactly yes there's too many dogs i have
the same thought
it's creeping me out dude it is it's
creepy there's something off about it
give me some trauma yeah
that's horrific yeah so at least it
doesn't look like that
the new iphone someday it's just going
to be all lined with cameras
about 30 cameras
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
uh
so oh here we go here's a here yeah
here's
this is actually a glimpse into the
future of tech
it looks like a bubble wrapping
anyone
any laughter
is this a meme or is that real
that is hard to tell considering
no i know okay
i said bubble wrapping
i said it looks like bubble wrap
wait hold on
it's actually real
no it's not
is that
um real think so
why would that be real
it's called the l16 camera i'm not sure
if it's yours for me too much laughter
dan
they're just it's so [ __ ] funny what
are you too much just too much just how
how do the lenses overlap uh
love is this real
i'm trying to find out for sure but the
article makes it seem like it's real
unless it's tough how can that be real
they're overlapping it's not even a good
photoshop
really
look at this they're tucked they're like
the plastic is like overlapping
all right
looks like bubble wrapping though
doesn't it
what the freak
[Applause]
zach is so upset
look at him
[Laughter]
it's all about timing dan shut the [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
jesus
damn what happened there a little
resentment towards me yeah what was that
resentment towards you yeah you're the
one who's pouting over there i'm not
pouting yes you are wait why is that
pouting why am i pouting because i i
have a little sound board over here and
i played the laughing and he feels like
i'm stepping on his toes as well not at
all i'm really i'm trying to help you um
okay you don't call it a call wait what
happened what happened with the sound
bites that i'm missing did zach do
something no i just played the laughter
a minute ago yeah and what did zach do
that was pouting he he he wanted the
audience to know that he wasn't the one
that was doing the laughter right
exactly
oh
is that true zach yeah dan's got a
little generic sound so
you say that that level of sound is
beneath you no no like i'll play
laughter and stuff but like it was a
little overkill yeah it was overkill
yeah i was perfect because he was doing
this
he was asking
for
well
i feel a little bit like he's an artist
he wants yeah he wants to make sure he
has reputation
so here is something love sent me this
is the camera apparently it's real
yep
where's the photo of it being real oh
oh that does appear to be
wait what the hell i told you dude dude
what the [ __ ] no no you better find me a
better picture than this what do you
mean
i want a head-on shot i don't this this
is too insane like extraordinary claims
okay extraordinary evidence show me show
me a better photo
that was the initial one the initial one
was front and you said it was fake
okay wait
wait this is not real i would never send
anything fake wait stop stop stop this
is not a real phone this is adorama i
mean this is a real
retailer
no no no no no no
there's another link
hold on this can't be real
chad has my back
hold on what the heck i'm telling you
dude dude
why is this a thing bro we just got
we just got owned
you know what i apologize love i thought
cam photoshopped this as a laugh
i thought that was the same too man
no
[ __ ] way i am so sorry love
it's fine but why did they do this
why have they done this
why
why i'm serious why have they done this
i'm sure there's
someone that needs this
really someone
what a fly
because they have a bunch of eyes
yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i i'm not this big speak
person okay now is this real yeah this
one's real too
what the hell is happening
i can't tell what's wrong what's fake
anymore with these phones
dude i'm freaking scared wait but that
looks as real as this one
is real
no this one isn't real okay but it looks
the same it's as crazy as the other one
yeah
that looks like a case probably right no
i think cam just photoshopped this oh
really yeah
but wait what can you read the specs
like why does it need four five six
seven eight nine ten
lenses they stopped selling it for some
reason so
it says 16 lenses
it says
digital camera with 16 lenses
why so the original page the people who
were selling this is taken down so
they're not selling it anymore
but it's on adorama
yeah you could buy it i think that's
used oh so here 16 lenses baby can we
buy this
i want to buy it this is a this is a
relic man
yeah can you buy one everything yeah
serious we should buy it and let sam put
it in wrestling
and preserve it oh that's such a good
idea
it's like uh
yeah we should do that i found a review
from 2018 yeah really they're actually
saying
it's a fantastic piece of technology
futuristic
it has 16 lenses it's an engineering
marvel
it takes 16 different smartphone sizes
imaging modules and then it combines
them to create like a
giant
you know super high 14 pages
we don't care i don't want it i hate it
it's 14 people it better be a good
picture what is this this is not
they're just randomly placed
there's no way that those are
strategically placed and they say it is
that's a [ __ ] look at the left
they're not even aligned
they just like drift randomly
this was made by like homer you remember
when homer designed that sports car that
bankrupted his brother's company
that's what this is oh yeah
somebody's
somebody's kid designed somebody's dumb
brother made this and and they bankrupt
the company they were there evidently
[Music]
damn
tragic i i'm just i'm sorry i'm staying
on the silver i just can't believe this
is real
we should buy it
i hundred yeah buy one of these
i need to know what we're gonna do with
it why are we buying i need to know what
a 16 lens camera is a thousand dollars
on ebay we should buy it and use it as
our main camera
go to lens seven please
yeah
51 megapixel i mean that's all that's a
lot of megapixels well it has 16 pages
on page 14.
[Laughter]
all right enough
we have so much to get to
so hopelessly
behind
what is this cod dance is this good
i have to download it i can't stream it
from that link what uh
yeah right underneath is a link to the
original post was backed up all right
we've got the uh call of duty mobile oh
this is an ad tick tock ads are so out
of control man i know i'm gonna love
this
call of duty mobile dance tutorials
i can't
i gotta full screen it
are you serious bro
call of duty mobile dance tutorial
so you want to try it why we don't you
watch the tutorial you want to
it's not it's not the call of duty dance
it's the call of duty mobile dance
tutorial
okay yeah let's give it a shot
the school shooter like now shoot up
your school
look at the bodies
throw the grenade into the movie theater
no
i mean what are you doing dance tutorial
i hate this so much
sorry but no we don't love it
by the way just think like if you could
show this to someone during world war ii
who's just coming out of like
a gruesome war they were ptsd
shell shocked and then you'd be like hey
yeah anyway um
here's what we've been up to
here's what we've been up to
war is awesome
war is great
we love war
fun
dancing
good times call of duty mobile dance
tutorial they're like i
i've lost everything
war is fun
we
we love war
can you imagine
wow that's the worst thing i've seen man
that's horrifying
who is this kid
i've seen a lot of bad tick tock ads
dude it's crazy i don't know where
they're even gen like
where'd you find this guy
why him
it has 700 likes
[Laughter]
yeah
good [ __ ] uh we got some quartering
memes you know that's gonna be good
man
has four claw machines in his house does
he he's such a [ __ ] weirdo dude hey
there i'm jeremy and you've come to that
part of youtube where you might be
wondering how the heck you got here
together with my brother so wait is it
never seen this before this is before he
started grifting before he was banned
from uh magic tournaments before he was
okay before at all before his villain
origin story it was just a simple claw
machine review or he was rejected
in the in the seventh grade and
and went on a rampage against all women
yeah so the quartering before he went on
a right-wing grifting rampage
he was trying to be like a
carnival games gamer i mean this dude is
huh
okay just watch hey there i'm jeremy and
you just stopped
oh my god he's he's being serious he hit
us with the hay there oh yeah no i've
seen this video in the past when we were
hey there quartering stuff and uh it's
like a different different guy whole
different vibe hey there
have you heard about white replacement
theory
hey there i'm jeremy and you've come to
that part of youtube where you might be
wondering how the heck you got here
together with my beautiful wife and our
best friend brandon we're about as a
let's go brandon
obsessed with the arcade as anyone
specifically claw machines so obsessed
we've already bought four different
machines and have them in our houses
who is this for kids he's making this
for 12 year olds it's just things we
have claws in our houses would you like
to come over and play sometime
we also have candy
and you can sleep over too
we're not playing at home we record our
journeys as we travel across the country
trying to win as many prizes as humanly
possible we'll also show you how these
machines work what to look for and how
to win and while we're not clawing we're
going to show you how to win massive
tickets at a ton of different arcade
games so you can get that super sweet
loot that you
super sweet loot
see i wish you went down this road
you know that's more wholesome it's
quality content yeah
more pedo vibes honestly than also no
i'm not getting old
well knowing what we know about him now
right right
you know he's not exactly mr rogers is
he
you don't want to be his neighbor no one
need another reason to subscribe we also
do giveaways and we'll ship the prizes
anywhere in the world if you see us
winning on this channel we're probably
going to give it away go ahead become
part of the clawstruck crew and getting
notified every time yeah that's his
channel
by crushing that subscribe button today
crushing it i've already taken my pants
off
he was still posting on clawstroke as of
a year ago
well wait what we'll do most expensive
teddy bear in history i think that's his
wife i've never seen what she looks like
i mean i'm not judging her looks i just
want to know who is this woman who's
spending
his better life with jeremy
from 2017
[Music]
this thing of a jig is this hanging out
here
plus stream doesn't want to leave it
nice camera work
dude i said you just have 16 frames or
16 lenses on it
he wishes
[Music]
not much
okay really a vlog simple wholesome
content yeah just a vlog about a hobby
they have i think that's that's that's
great
his wife seems nice and normal from what
i can tell
go back to this dude
you were doing well look it had over 100
case subscribers
[Music]
no if it wasn't for immigrants trying to
replace white people maybe wouldn't have
to have made
made the quartering
uh oh uh oh women are amazing aren't
they like we truly just they like the
fact that there's a woman out there for
jeremy is just it's just a beautiful
story
like that's a positive spin you could
put on it like women are just amazing
like you this woman presumably
she touches him
like that's just that blows my mind
we love women don't we folks they're
incredible
shout out to jeremy's wife she seems
like a
nice lady
shout out will you do something about
jeremy please reign his ass in or
something man you seem you've seen she's
been trying that's why she goes out for
pizza without him when he's acting up
yeah
the man pisses in his basement it's time
to whip him into shape yeah come on
[Laughter]
okay so we've been i've been told not to
watch this one jordan peterson
friend of the show
idol
where's the bust
we i love the man so much we even have a
bust of him he wrote is this a rap song
or like a spoken word
so jordan peterson made a song
about justin trudeau
um
it was uh
justin trudeau has been causing quite a
bit of
toxic masculinity
what a horrible phrase that is
toxic masculinity
what's so horrible about wanting to spit
my wife's
eyes
during sex
after we watch this zach do you want to
drop your jordan rap that you were doing
earlier
yeah sure zac
came what's going on with justin he's
like
i know there's like they're getting sick
and tired of these [ __ ] truckers
blocking all the trade routes from the
us to canada and so they're starting to
rest them all and so they used an
emergency power thing that uh apparently
has been around in canada since the 80s
but this is the first time anybody's
actually invoked it it's basically like
a martial law kind of thing yeah
to uh arrest them and get them out of
the way and so a lot of people are
saying he's basically hitler for doing
that elon musk actually did email a musk
man this guy is such a piece of [ __ ] i'm
so over him
i'm like
i don't think i'll ever get another
tesla again
i mean i have one on lease currently so
but that was before disclosure
but i don't think i'll get another tesla
like he's that he's that disgusting he
posted this
and then erased it i guess but like he
said stop comparing me a picture of
hitler to justin trudeau i had a budget
well he's both saying justin trudeau is
hitler and also saying hitler
is he's saying if hitler's justin
trudeau he's not that bad of a guy let's
be honest he's kind of defending hitler
here in a way
also
it's just factually incorrect like nazi
germany ran a giant [ __ ] deficit like
they ran the economy into the [ __ ]
ground because the whole idea was we'll
just conquer our neighbors and take
their money well they had millions of
slaves that helped yeah that helps too
so
it's pretty it's pretty convenient to
grow your economy when you have slaves
doing everything that you don't even
provide food or shelter for
it's awesome definitely helps
uh what the [ __ ] bro elon musk you're
such a piece of [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] you
he's he's meaning too close to the sun
here
[Music]
i'm out
i liked elon musk before he joined
twitter
god what why would you tweet this
what is even the comparison to justin
trudeau he just wants to the trucker's
gone i mean what am i missing
has he killed anyone has he
has he uh
invaded a neighboring country what has
he done
is he arrested some protesters which
you know you can discuss that on the
merits maybe that is bad but um
but that's not has did he murder did he
systematically kill them white rising
based on racial the level of nazi
germany not quite not yet but it's a
slippery slope man it starts with it
starts with the
arresting a bunch of hogs and pickup
trucks and uh next thing you know you
got camps
didn't i heard something about he's
freezing their bank accounts is that
true well not the individuals but the
organizations that were uh funding it
they
got the banks to
shut it down or something and they had
already they were originally doing like
gofundme [ __ ] and i think gofundme shut
them down and so then they tried to
switch to crypto
uh funding somehow and i guess they're
also blocking that so yeah by the way i
saw
that jordan peterson is speaking at some
crypto con
yeah the bitcoin conference the bitcoin
con it's like what the [ __ ] does he have
to do with bitcoin why is this being
co-opted by conservatives i even
well
some would argue it's always been a
conservative movement but it's at least
a libertarian movement but um okay
liberty okay yeah but um yeah regardless
i i actually saw on the um
the reactions to it on the main like
like our bitcoin on reddit and even they
were like what the [ __ ] is this guy
doing here he's not he's not doesn't
know anything about crypto no i've never
seen him talk about crypto before
apparently he started to get on
it
very recently but that was the kind of
comments i was seeing was like why are
they having a dude who understood what
bitcoin was like two weeks ago as like
uh yeah he understood it when he got a
lucrative job off uh speaking offer yeah
oh i like crypto
by the way guys
i have officially decided
to stop working with crypto companies
right
sorry would you say i was reading
something we have i've officially
decided to stop working with crypto
companies that is true that is true you
know in the past i feel like i knew i
didn't but i feel like i've come to the
decision
that i think kryptos is a basically a
giant ponzi scheme i'm sorry
it's basically a giant scam
and one of the hugest brokers was trying
to do a deal with us and it breaks my
heart to tell you that we passed on it
uh it was so much money you guys it was
so huge
and
it hurts it's painful
but it is a scam
and uh get your money out while you can
anyway let's watch
i just want to give as much background
as possible here
oh dude what the [ __ ] is this
[Music]
you better [ __ ] stop this [ __ ] right
now dude
wake up
okay jordan
[Music]
this is pretty uh avant-garde here
let me go back because i wasn't quite
registering what the [ __ ] was that
[Music]
this is
unredeemably
the worst thing i've ever heard
what is this
when i first saw it i said to the
guys that it's like the
like the song they'll play while they're
brainwashing you in clockwork orange
it's just like pounding your [ __ ]
skull it's like i don't know it's like
pink floyd propaganda
i get it now
i just went straight to the comments
professor peterson you have an army of
people that support you keep going
where would we be without my cold
of
lobsters we're coming to the government
building
okay let me just i gotta focus
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh yeah it's a total it's pink void like
floyd
is that roger
oh my god though it's like it's like
pink floyd pro fascism right it's
impressive yeah it's kind of like the
opposite of what they are opening floyd
demos from the wall
[Music]
you should be reading the 12 rules
you
should be buying busts of my face
only two hundred dollars today
i'm not a cult leader i just sell busts
of my face for 300 bucks
shipping not included uh he doesn't sell
them himself he promoted it
so he's definitely he's definitely
getting he's getting a piece of the
other guacamole he claimed he didn't i
don't know if that's [ __ ] why would
you promote that yeah
liar
how dare you call me a liar bucko
what are you up to ethan
[Music]
yeah we're all gonna die
like in a horrific war
[Music]
why is this on jordan's channel
because this is his song
he wrote this and he's singing in it
no he's not singing yeah look at
look at the
look at the description
it's multiple people singing
composed by jordan how did you compose
this you don't know and his good friend
scotch tully
don't you tell me you composed this
lyrics by jordan b peterson voices sonia
tully tammy peterson scotch tully jordan
b peterson i believe tammy peterson is
his wife
wake up dedicated under the current
unfortunate conditions to the prime
minister of canada the right honorable
justin trudeau
yeah
man he's so desperate to be a victim
it's like it's like the biggest
inconvenience is the holocaust these
days
maybe you should just go to sleep
you i wish you would go to sleep and
leave us all the [ __ ] alone don't wake
up you know it's funny because benzos
make you sleep right they make you
sleepy
i believe so yeah so
more aptly called going to sleep
passing out and waking up in a strung
out a bed in russia
or like serbia or something was it
maybe it was russia that would be a way
more interesting topic of i'd love to
hear that i mean that's po someday maybe
we'll get the whole
real story of what down with all that
his daughter will tell the story
that her telephone
i don't know if i trust her version of
it
you don't trust her
the woman who advocates for eating meat
only
why are they doing this
dude you're so sick in the [ __ ] head
to be showing those images
you're just talking about some mega
truckers that won't [ __ ] why are you i'm
assuming this is like a concentration
camp
choose a side
yeah
dude you're showing a starving child in
a concentration camp and you're just mad
about some [ __ ] truckers bro who are
blocking interstate
trade because they don't want to wear a
mask you idiot
um
yeah and i mean i apolog like to our
canadian viewers i apologize if we're
not summarizing the situation uh
completely accurate
i depend on dan for that but i asked dan
don't get mad at me get mad at danny's
supposed to know this stuff get mad at
me um i don't think i say anything that
inaccurate though i i look into that law
that they invoked and everything it was
the first time they've ever uh used it
maybe describing his martial law isn't
quite well regardless
if he's a douche or whatever
he's not hitler guys right yeah there's
still a wide gap but i don't know blame
dan don't get mad at me
are people mad
i don't think so okay i was just saying
because i you know i'm just speaking off
the dome and i'm not
following this whole kerfuffle because
you don't walk back like that
you walked it back a bit i always i
always hedge my bets
yeah uh anyways the um
the
truckers from what i understand uh
the the support for that um
protest has uh
waned significantly um from already
fairly low support
and the truckers themselves that are
getting in the room
the vaccine mandates and everything
something like 80 of canadian truckers
are vaccinated
um
so
the the slice of people protesting
aren't necessarily representative i said
get in loser
we're unvaxed and ready to [ __ ]
let the peasants die a covered
we've got we've got regeneron
these they feel so self-important
especially jordan
you could say like joe rogan
and elon musk have achieved things
jordan
has
such a [ __ ] self look how
self-important he looks right there
like what have you done except be a dick
like these guys are trail blazers at
least
as much as i just like them 83 to 87
of truckers in canada are vaccinated
so that kind of gives you an idea of
yeah
there's lots of okay whatever let's just
yeah
let's go
literally hitler
[Music]
wow look at that dude what a transition
windows movie maker 2005 for sure dude
get out your lighters everyone let's get
them in the air
wailing
i don't even know what they're showing
it's a girl with a cigarette and a crow
on her shoulder what am i supposed to
take from this
genuinely white heritage
that's what it seems like right
definitely what it is so jordan actually
reached out to me to play the solo on
this so that oh [ __ ] that's you yeah
that's me shredding oh no wonder yeah no
wonder i was vibing with that
did you tell them you're jewish because
this they just did like a whole white
heritage thing changed my last name wait
are you serious is this a white
heritage thing oh i i was just no i
don't but like what the [ __ ] else is it
i i don't know
this whole thing was just baffling i
couldn't believe it was i don't know
that is not jordan singing
well there's again four vocalists are
credited uh so i don't know um
where jordan is and where
uh his uh
with scotch tully or whatever the
weirdest name ever made
oh i can hear him in there a bit
[Music]
it's just
[Music]
i hate it
they should be embarrassed but
they're not
and the people watching like it
i think it'd be cool if you did like a
rap song
[ __ ] yeah
maybe way better
by the way
the auschwitz museum came on top of uh
came to dunk on elon musk he's suing
them for defamation no
no just kidding
okay
i'm suing the auschwitz memorial center
they said using the image of adolf
hitler and therefore exploiting the
tragedy of all people who suffered were
humiliated tortured and murdered by
tiltarian regime of nazi germany created
by him
is sad and disturbing it disrespects the
memory of all victims and hurts many
people
yeah he's right
canada sanctions 34 crypto wallets tied
to trucker freedom convoy right there
you go that's what i was referencing
with the crypto stuff where does he even
get this like where did he get this meme
facebook what [ __ ] just
yeah i mean it seems like a stupid
boomer meme it's just you you have to
kind of be in like a really
[ __ ] up circle to even receive this
meme
there you go and i know it's like the
least important part but again it's just
really annoying hitler had a budget
he ran deficits you know what i mean
like it's not like
it's just so stupid it's just that's
your problem
hitler did have a wait hitler didn't
have a budget
no right he didn't he had a budget no
that what i'm saying is that they they
ran up massive deficits while
he was in power he was
they're they're trying to imply like you
think canada has better finances
yeah because their whole economy isn't
predicated on conquering or
basically all or nothing right take it
all or yeah there you go touche [ __ ]
got him
what else
what else uh we should probably do our
ads we're uh 45 minutes actually you
know it's exciting we're getting uh yeah
we'll do our ads but
the pizza that loves been going on and
on about the kebabs
yeah it's on its way we found a place
do you want do you want to say anything
about it love
i do want to say that
they claim to have authentic swedish
pizza
now i'm very very very doubtful of that
they claim to have a what like an
authentic swedish pizza it's called like
viking pizzeria or something right i
know it's the real deal
[Laughter]
i don't know dude i saw the pictures the
pizzas themselves looked like home
i saw the kebab it looks somewhat
similar the sauce though didn't look
exactly the same so i'm a bit
on the fence i told him he had to call
and speak to them in swedish to get the
real did you do that no i actually
didn't bother oh you should have done
that that would have been so good they
hide that [ __ ] in the back that's not
for americans that's that's for swedes
only
well nobody's looking for that pizza but
sweets let's be honest nobody's looking
out viking pizza that still puts kebab
and [ __ ]
lettuce on their pizza like it's
lunatics but i just want to warn
everyone that it might not be authentic
okay well you'll let us know yeah i'm
ready for that
cool well i'm excited for that that's
coming up next and so much more but
first thank you to our sponsor honey
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer
um
what do we got here this is a recent say
ela i got a whole album of recent ones
because uh ela's been going crazy just
scroll through them because this is
unbelievable this is real
ela's does our shopping obviously she's
buying furniture food this one's 20
21.50 off a 140 percent 10 yeah that's
[ __ ] good it's like so amazing i
can't emphasize how much i love honey
and how much you need
to have it installed you don't have to
think about it dude thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past it's honey is free
it's a shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and
automatically applies the best one it
finds to your car
so you're shopping on your favorite site
when you check out the honey button
appears and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons that it can
find for that site and if honey finds a
coupon you're going to watch the price
drop magically
yeah you've seen it it saved us at this
point it saved me a heal of thousands of
dollars it's it's ridiculous from
like bedding stuff carpets even food
video game or like computer related
stuff
you know all these big retailers they've
got coupons floating around and honey
brings it all home for you
uh it honey doesn't just work on
desktops now it's also on your iphone
just activate it on safari on your phone
and save on the go
so if you don't already have honey
you're gonna be straight up missing out
on free money and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show
i wouldn't recommend honey if i didn't
use it myself
i love it
get honey for free at joinhoney.com h3tv
that's joinhoney.com
h3tv thank you
[Music]
and finally thank you to stamps
time is money people
don't waste either with repeated trips
to the post office with stamps.com you
can skip the trip and focus on how to
take your small business to the next
level that's stamps.com
let you print official postage right
from your computer and it saves you
money in the process so you can spend
less time at the post office and more
time making your customers happy
your girlfriend uses stamps right dad
she does
she uh for her online business she sells
her art sells prints and all that kind
of stuff
skirts.com that skirts with three that's
good that you get the plug or when you
do that why not yeah um but yeah she's
been a customer for years and uh i i see
how it all works and it really couldn't
be more simple if you if you ship a lot
of things it's a great service it is
super convenient you're able to just
print all the shipping labels straight
from your computer
and slap them on the package postman
picks it up or drop it off at the post
office whatever you want to do it's easy
as could be
it actually seems like a great service
and it's cheaper
than going to the post office too very
much so yeah i'm kind of a no-brainer
like that
it saves you time money and stress
for more than 20 years stamps.com has
been indispensable for over a million
businesses stamps.com gives you access
to the post office and ups shipping
services you need
right from your computer
and the discounts let me tell you you
get 40 off usps rates and 76
off ups okay wow
uh whether you're in office sending
invoices or a side hustle etsy shop or
full-blown warehouse shipping out orders
stamps.com will make your life easier
all you need is a computer and standard
printer no special supplies or equipment
you're up and running minutes print an
official postage for any letter any
package anywhere you want to send it
stop overpaying for shipping with
stamps.com sign up at stamps.com
h3tv for a special offer that includes a
four week trial free postage and a
digital scale there's no long-term
commitment or contracts just head on
over to stamps.com
h3 tv
thank you
thank you thank you peace and love just
found out big announcement at the next
astro world no way
that's huge yep
he's the actually what i read is he's
the only performing artist there
yep everyone else can
um
he's headlining
real quick apparently um
uh our boy corbin donated a hundred
dollars asking
dan
we need to know what build you're going
uh in elden ring which i think first of
all both of us thank you yeah
corbin corbin which makes me thinks of
the fifth element
corbin dallas but thank you so much uh
what build i don't know anything about
the game
uh well i i've purposely stayed in the
dark for a decent amount of it i have
watched very little footage from all the
uh
the those beta tests that came out and
streamers were streaming the first chunk
of the game i'm
trying to keep it pure but
usually when in all those games i
usually just do a standard like strength
build me too
strength build
magic's for [ __ ] dude
you gotta go hard you gotta go hard i
have heard that the magic is a lot more
interesting in this one than it has been
in the previous games so i might that's
true without a little bit yeah i just
like being i just like slamming bombing
stuff slam bam
bam
rolling dodging
magic's too easy
it is it kind of nerfs the game a little
bit in the previous ones but i don't
know if it'll be like that in this one
maybe it maybe they've put more focus on
it all right so here's jeff's patreon
video once again he cannot sue us this
is fair use especially since he met well
it doesn't matter but he does mention me
he says [ __ ] h3 at 11 50.
cool
so shout out so [ __ ] you too jeff i'm
glad you ass glad we took the time to
try and be sympathetic to him yeah okay
ethan
well at least i didn't help cover up a
girl r-worded
so [ __ ] me but [ __ ] you at the same time
you know
at least i didn't cover up for a friend
to try to kill me
well let's watch
um let's watch
jeff weddick
so this is the live stream where he
basically goes masks off
on david he unfollowed him on instagram
it's a full mask off moment here and i
was when i first thought i was like what
happened to his eye because like i guess
he just got his ninth eye surgery nine
out of ten
they knew that there would be 10
surgeries when they started initially i
don't think he knew that
yeah
i feel bad for him even though he says
[ __ ] me i do
i feel like we could have been we could
have had an understanding uh
if uh our path our paths crossed
differently you were always uh i'm pro
jeff what can i say yeah you were always
a little bit lighter on him then i try
to be i try to be empathetic to the guy
even though i really hate people with
one eye
i'm just kidding
what the [ __ ] i'm just kidding i don't
know i'm just kidding around
just giving him a hard time we love our
we love our cyclop phobia dude
we love our people with one eye don't we
folks
i'm overcoming a deep phobia of people
with one eye
he has two eyes come on
with the medium like that
are we good
super high quality stream by the way
15 a month guys this could all be yours
w if the stream is good i don't even
know who these goons are
and why does this guy have a band-aid
over his eye is he just in solidarity or
something he said he's doing it as a
social experiment to see what jeff's
going through so they could discuss
another podcast so [ __ ] interesting
great that's so interesting dude i don't
know how serious they were but
that's so cool you should write a book
about that
nothing now froze
oscar
are we good
15 bucks a month guys
that's right there we go
i'm going to repeat what i just said
because i was talking um i guess to
nobody this is ryan here
this is where the man from utah
is a good friend he's wearing a band-aid
over his eye he's been doing this for
the last six hours
to uh
put himself in my shoes so he can feel
how i feel
and it's it's actually very nice him i
don't want him to do it i keep telling
him to take it off because it's like
disturbing it i don't want to see him go
through pain for me
but it's also kind of funny that he's
actually committed i didn't think
him and stephen both decided to do it at
the same time but stephen crapped out
afterwards so anyway uh let's skip to
the action because let's face it as
compelling as this content is
there's more specific moments to watch
one at five minutes so here we go
remember guys jeff woodack patreon this
called be yours for 15 a month a little
plug for him
and as he got close to us you're like
well well get the [ __ ] back steaming
because you hear cracking
but i talked on about 20 lb's ever since
he made it big and he's eating good he's
a lot of money now as david messaged you
to see if you're okay
nope not a text or nothing uh
not surprised you know is what it is but
i'm done being fake friends with that
[ __ ] so that that's hey can you
add something i actually i genuinely
feel bad i mean this guy is loyal i
would say loyal to a fault right because
he's like this like hey i'm a criminal
we don't snitch on nobody
hey i don't i didn't see nothing about
nobody
what happened to the girl i ain't no i
wasn't there oh i was there oh well i
don't know i don't remember
i can't this i don't see so good i don't
remember
[Laughter]
i got brain damage what can i do i don't
remember nothing
i'm just he's playing up his stuff
so he can't recall to the police but
anyway i genuinely feel bad for him
because he's like loyal to a fault to
david
and uh
david doesn't give a [ __ ] about him and
he finally realized that he was used he
was almost killed and the guy he can't
even check up on him he has lifelong
injuries
and it's like dude he's he's just such a
piece of [ __ ] david dobrik
and jeff tried so hard to like make good
with him too you know he gave him every
benefit of the doubt
he gave him so many chances and david
still can't call him up
and say how's the eye that's it that's
all he wants
how's the eye
take it out there stop it stop it
um
how much for the plate and the screw
um
i'll get i'll do a giveaway honestly
i don't know maybe when i get 25 it's
the next moment
he's giving away a plate and screw out
of his head
people in the chat were asking for it he
was
making a joke out of it okay yeah i was
like i don't know if that's
legal
um uh
yeah
what's going on in here
you deserve much better we want steve
what a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong
with david i mean it is what it is you
know that's how he is and i tried enough
to protect his image and
you know now i just don't give a [ __ ] i
unfollow them on instagram
mostly because this [ __ ] sucks and i
don't want to see it but
also that's interesting to hear him
finally say
what we've all known but none of them
would speak out and say that they've
been protecting him
they've all been protecting him
cam
what's funny saying show me it
oh he's oh well that's that's actually
cool yeah i mean
that's uh of course guts yeah
it's a good luck
he's part of the bossy
kick
would that make david oh david's griffin
yeah he's just gonna say he's totally
great
griffin
oh whoa
so because it pisses me off that he
can't send the [ __ ] text to be like
hey i know your surgery was like 30
maybe you lose your eye or not
but um nothing you know he promoted his
vlog so i'm happy i just wish to jeff
like he's putting this behind a patreon
paywall i wish he would just
everyone's just doesn't want to say it
just just be out there and be like [ __ ]
this guy he ruined my life he doesn't
care about me they just won't say it and
i think he he had to have known that
this would
cause waves yeah he mentions that it's
probably gonna be on twitter also he
says he wants to talk about it more on
the podcast okay good i hope he does
i hope he does because i think people
need to just say it
just own it i mean he's the first one
who's actually saying it which is good
i think they're just afraid of david's
fans because there's a huge overlap and
then they'll be like
you're a [ __ ] snake you get that
every time on the internet you're a
snake bro he only tried to kill you and
then forgot you exist
how dare you
he also mentions i mean i believe it's
that but also that he's still close
friends with a lot of other members of
the vlog squad and doesn't want it to
fall right like when scientology you
leave scientology you lose everyone
right turns against you
i think there might be a problem in your
friend group dude
just saying
he promoted his [ __ ] vlog so yeah
jeff's on a lot of drugs
how many drugs you have right now a lot
i feel like this is me on frenemies
again
uh why did you read the article i can't
my eyes don't work [ __ ] i wish
i could have told them that back then
but i was protecting
this [ __ ] and this story and all
this [ __ ] yeah i'm getting too out of
control here yeah so we have and having
candy over here kenzie made up really
well they cut him off
he wasn't getting out of control it's
good to hear you talk your mind
why are you afraid to speak your mind
jeff
if he would have just been honest with
us at the time
yeah maybe it would be
you'd probably be looking really good
out of that interview for actually being
honest
what about an excavator
yeah i seen an excavator
with one eye
yeah yeah what about an excavator i
don't know nothing oh my god yeah i used
to work construction so what
he's uh what do they call it like johnny
johnny tight lips
yeah they call me johnny tight lips i
ain't saying nothing about nobody
he thinks he's a mobster
that's what i do
ain't seen nothing
you feel like jeff what'd you eat for
lunch today who's asking
mind your own business
jeff did you see your mom on the weekend
what
i didn't see nothing
the bottom line is you cannot be trusted
i'm mac and cheese this is nav
oscar is i think six hours away he's
drove up here
um
if you freeze a caprice on it's like a
little slushy
yeah if you freeze a capri sun it turns
into a slushie
anyway david almost killed me
yeah
i'm going a little off the rails cut to
the capri sun
all right now bring it back
[Music]
all right 11 minutes he's back on he's
back on the rails we're back off the
rails
ever since the surgery
david's gonna be trending on twitter
tonight who gives a [ __ ] no he's not his
clout's over he's done it's washed up
nobody cared oh wow okay here's about
him anymore
um but honestly i do feel bad that like
you know i have so many other friends
that are in between us that i don't want
to lose so take it easy you know
nobody's mad at them dude i just don't
like did you're literally describing a
call
but he's saying take it ease
take goodies take it east
we all go to hey
we all going down together
you know what i'm saying loose lips sink
ships cubbies
come on
um
that was really masked off there that
was eye off there let's listen like all
right
too much
come on
i'm biting my tongue you kind of you
gotta chill
it's just comedy i know and it's making
me laugh but
it's a little a little unsensitive
it's it is insensitive
stop laughing that's why it's funny it's
funny it's funny it's fine who cares
i'm fat he has one eye
we all have our disabilities come on
it's not his fault
it isn't his fault it's david that's the
point it's not his fault he's doing his
best to overcome i think he's i think
it's heroic what he's going through okay
okay that's good i'm not saying he's a
bad guy because he has one eye
i know you're not i know you're done
it's not people angry at me
maybe no i don't have the chat open
let's just go with now
why you say it like that because yes
some people are oh they're mad at me
but i don't know how representative that
is
well guys i mean he does have one eye
like that's a fact
literally not the fact he has to yeah he
has two eyes you're right so you see
nothing it's all lucy goosey it's all
jokes
the man has two eyes
does the joke is not even factually
correct
okay
stop laughing it's not funny
it was actually his third eye that was
crushed good job zach thank you
all right let's listen to this again
surgery david's gonna be trending on
twitter tonight who gives a [ __ ] no he's
not his clown's over he's done it's
washed up nobody cares about him anymore
is that almost like there's no more
juice to get from him so now i'm gonna
expose him a little bit
he's washed up
is he washed up at me and i feel like
he's still a big audience okay so that's
a really good interesting point to hear
from jeff i mean he is not getting any
big opportunities he did just have that
amp that uh discovery show which i don't
think did
remarkably well
but his channel is doing okay but the
thing is about david is that he almost
reached this level of fame that was like
every youtuber dreams of i guess
but then
he's back making youtube videos
um
the views are great though so i'm gonna
call him washed up would you
like yeah he's still five million six
million eight million yeah i don't know
if that like maybe that's a downgrade
from
what his numbers used to be but those
are still huge yeah
for sure yeah i mean he used to get like
20 per video which is
pretty nuts but uh
so yeah he's had a drop off but i
wouldn't call getting 5 million views
washed up
no people still care about david
now james charles on the other hand
is he washed up
have you guys seen james charles new
look
man i'm talking about the hair the
jizzling maxwell look this is jizzling
uh he's getting a million per video
which is a lot obviously but a lot less
and that's good he shouldn't be getting
he's getting
10
i mean
like 10 million
a video james was getting a lot more
than that i think
when he was collabing with like the
kardashians and stuff man he was pushing
crazy numbers bro this one has 50
million 30 million
10 15 15. so that's good i'm glad people
are stopped watching this
this guy's the worst person on the
internet by far sister
i don't know by far yeah maybe not
listen let's hold out that title
that's true
um but honestly i do feel bad that like
you know i have so many other friends
that are in between us that i don't want
to lose so take it easy you know
but like i'm done being fake i can never
be fake with you guys
you could never be fake i mean you mean
except for the years
leading up to this where you covered up
and then you go well his clout has run
out so now i'll be real with you guys i
mean he released an entire documentary
film that the arc of it was like him
forgiving david and them like making
amends and becoming friends again and
stuff so was that fake yes
i mean yeah that's true and again i'm
not i'm not blaming him i i don't want
to misplace my anger jeff jeff is
i really want to say he's a good guy i
want to put that out there but
dan won't let me
well
don't put that on me
you can make your own judgment right
yeah you've always for some reason i
like jeff even though he hates my guts
trust me bro i get it
i just i get it
i can't see the
the [ __ ]
i don't know where we are okay here
we're gonna watch a little bit longer um
and i tried for so long to give
everybody a chance but it's just
there you go he says he tried for so
long to give everyone a chance see he's
a great guy love jeff there's david here
we got to cut that [ __ ] off right
there's logan
what did i do how many of the cries have
you had today at least i never claimed
to be your friend
yeah listen he puts me in the same uh
breath with david no [ __ ] ethan too and
[ __ ] david what did i do
i've always been straight up with you
bro
always been
i cl and i clout you up more than david
does
very true you know what i mean when's
the last time david did anything for you
a clout need that clout i mean yeah
right
i gotta hear that again that's a good
sound bite right zach
uh
honest
i mean yeah
come on the show jeff i feel like we can
make amends i would love to have you
back so
you're weird
you're jeff simp
am i a little bit it just seems like he
can do like even you literally
i want to like him i know
because i feel like he's a victim
who else
could we be reacting to a video where he
was just like offhand and like [ __ ] h3
that you'd be like i like this guy
anybody else you wouldn't be going i
guess
i'm not very like threatened by his uh
i mean the dude by his hostility the
dude's a stud like all jesus i didn't
say i want to [ __ ] him zach
what are you saying
nah jeff's got that like i don't know so
what jeff's the only handsome guy i've
ever talked about
maybe that you like have beefed with
he's probably the most handsome guy that
you've beefed with
i mean who else are you i'm not making
these qualifications the polls
i'm just saying the dude's a good
looking dude okay so i want to [ __ ] him
that's what you're saying i did did i
say that i'm i might be implying that
what the [ __ ] is this what is happening
to my eye
yo dude yeah you [ __ ]
jeff has a few questions for this
[Laughter]
someone in chat
mentioned that david had this video i
wonder if that pissed jeff off i bet it
did
what's happening mike you guys my eye
it's just like a mosquito bite or
something
that was just clickbait for the day not
that good
what happened to my eye
would you click that
maybe me yeah
well he's david's no i'm just i'm asking
is that good clickbait what happened to
my eye
being that he [ __ ] up jeff's eye for
life yes i would definitely click that
oh you think it was a reference to the
i don't know if it's intentional but i'm
curious
so maybe i should do one for this
episode what happened to my eye
maybe
maybe we could crop out
jeff's damaged eye and put it over mine
insensitive
no comment
how many of the croys have you had today
i've been drinking like 12 lacroix a day
dude that's super interesting bro
he's doing a q a from his fan no no no
no this is why i love jeff he's really
good he's super interesting
let's go back i want to hear that
question
[Laughter]
honest
i mean yeah
she going oh h3 now [ __ ] him too
how many of the crows have you had today
i've been drinking like 12 lacroix a day
yeah that's awesome
hotel room because we were in a hotel
for the first couple days so
i was just dude that's crazy
slam in lacroix no food because i didn't
have an appetite right and
that's awesome bro
that's such an epic anecdote
all right next one is that what
i wonder what i can't wait
on the subreddit like three hours
there's gonna be a video of us talking
about lacroix or something
i like recording
i'm just joking we've had long
conversations about how what we drank
okay i'm giving him a hard time come on
you are just making jokes why am i the
one that's defending him do you want to
[ __ ]
all right
i took a baseball bat to an excavator in
your honor
thank you chad
you want to do something in my honor
take a baseball bat
okay i'm not going
it's a good name
said a stage name
it's crazy after one accident how many
surgeries you can have
i know
i know i wish i would have known in the
beginning that it was going to be this
much of a headache because that would
pop you know
how long is your recovery process
probably like a week no
yeah where's vince hanging out with
david
what are you saying
where's vince hanging out with david
who's vince
i don't know
i mean is that it or is there more that
was it just saying that if he would have
known there had been that much surgery
he would have clocked david
i would have clocked them one all right
updated thumb
no i hate it no
you look i think you look you like it
kind of fire yeah kind of funny let's
see
david looks so stupid in that photo
what the [ __ ] is that
quagmire dude
i asked cam to make a meme he's probably
working on it but let me just show you
jeff come on my show
he's literally this guy
yeah i mean that's he invented that guy
basically
now you should check the display yeah
show a cam just oh he did naked okay
nice
you guys it's a double rainbow
it's a double rainbow you guys
david's face
what the hell is he doing
dude
whoa
it's so stretched oh i don't even know
i'm trying to like do it
[Music]
there's like kind of a side
you have to like shift your jaw yeah i
can't have to like dislocate my jaw
wait here's the original
oh my god he posted that yeah
my first ever photo dump
dude what
all right let's check out the photo dump
they call them dumps
oh sh
oh [ __ ] it's a picture of jeff head
first in the water
he didn't mean to put that in here oops
i should do a photo dome
it's just pictures of theodore though
basically oh there's a photo dump
can i like this oh i can't
dude it's got so much swag bro swag
theodore's got crazy swag too
i'm the only schlub in that house
oh we went to this place called
adventure city over the weekend
it's near disneyland but it's made for
specifically like two three-year-olds
it's really fun theodore loved it nice
it's great
oh and bruce
you guys posted
a picture of bruce the other day and uh
a lot of people were pointing out that
he looks a lot like you
well he is my son yeah so there you go
proof sorry keemstar
but like theodore like looks you think
he looks more like me theodore looks
like ela and you mixed for sure yeah
bruce at least i mean obviously he's
like two weeks old he's
my boss but right now he definitely
looks like well he's my little batman
there you go
young master bruce that's what i call
him master bruce young master bruce
your breakfast is ready
wait there's another part i should watch
oh i already closed it [ __ ] here let me
see if i can open it we'll have to rebuy
i don't recall how good it is though i
could let me screen it real quick no i i
got it what's the timestamp 36
oh my god
okay
36.
are we good l if the stream is bad but
this
probably i don't know maybe i i will
maybe i won't but it's not just the text
thing here you know there's more [ __ ]
going on but
um
i'm doing all right after surgery
thank you for stopping keeping it on
really just alluding to there's more
than just him not texting him wait let
me go back a little because i missed the
we'll put the silver right guy if they
like them
we're in um thoughts on kanye on
instagram last week that was pretty cool
it's fun it's entertaining hey david
there's a lot of [ __ ] on david here like
look guys i'll i'll talk more about this
probably i don't know maybe i i will
maybe i won't but it's not just the text
thing here you know there's more [ __ ]
going on but
um
all righty
well i hope david's supposed to be
paying for all of his medical stuff
wasn't that like part of the uh
redemption what i i wonder if he's still
paying for the ninth surgery he better
be yeah i wonder if that's what's uh
driving the wedge
i wonder if it's too late for him to sue
him
if there is there
i don't think there's a statute of
limitation on civil lawsuits is there
no and i mean i doubt it would be past
that i mean that only happened like a
year and a half ago right he should sue
him still man two years ago maybe
that that's
bro that's like such an easy win lawsuit
and that's how david skirt's
responsibility because he's convinced
everyone you're gonna hurt all your
friends you're gonna hurt me you're
gonna be a rat
meanwhile david should be penniless
for what he did
to both those people
anyway that's that what do you guys
think what do you think uh where's our
pizza bro
how far away is this place did you drive
to sweden
yeah yeah
it was it was fairly far but uh she'll
probably be back soon
call her ian
get her on the line
where the [ __ ] is the pizza um well in
the meantime
there was a
safe moon lawsuit
oh yeah safe moon
baby
safe moon as we i was talking about how
crypto and nfts are pretty much scams
and i'm over
working with them or
i mean i i've come to the real it's been
a slow coming realization i mean
obviously there's been like
[ __ ] coins like safe moon
i mean we sold nfts here on this show
right that was just like an experiment i
mean it wasn't but yeah we still don't
think really any of us even knew what
the [ __ ] was going on like that was sort
of like it was an exploratory segment
i mean the one that i uh
i still have a bridge to say yeah i
literally made it that cause i thought
from the beginning that the whole thing
just seemed rare but that was about nfts
i think most people are starting to come
around the nfts are just like
so stupid
they get a lot of hate online yeah a lot
of hate [ __ ] up but i think crypto
itself i'm starting to turn and think
like actually
i think crypto is just straight up
pretty bad news
open c yeah here's your here is your um
nft that you made what like ten thousand
dollars
selling
is that i still like i'm just
the whole thing was just so baffling
like who bought this
a dude named uh kushari angels bought
this stamp
by the way is anyone have any is there
any activity on any of our i don't think
no
yeah zero you've been checking
yeah yeah i mean i'm not surprised
who the hell
yeah
now here's now here you want to talk
activity
here's garyvee and his dad making out
by the way whatever happened with this
we never we didn't actually mint these
can we mint these
no let's not can we transfer them to
garyvee
his wallet erratically you couldn't do
that
but
[Laughter]
wait you got offers on it did you know
that
yeah
i don't know i didn't i didn't want to
mint it because then that's like the you
know wait it says it was logical here a
month ago
doesn't it wait it does say that it's
minted yeah
i didn't pay anything normally you have
to pay right you have to like pay a fee
you have a real one it says right here
you have minted this thing a month ago
and someone offered point one ethereum
which is like 200 bucks
or 300 bucks for it right
changes by the hour i don't know
yeah i don't know well
you're trying to are you trying to sling
these on the side no that's not i mean
if you already mentioned my christmas
gift
if you already did you meant it no i
didn't meant it but who meant it meaning
our negotiations i don't know i'm saying
if you already minted it i thought you
had to pay to men to mint something
frenching fathers
i just uploaded a picture i didn't know
i just i'm gonna check your crypto
wallet ian
ian friends
it's not even linked to a wallet there's
nothing
wait you made this shoe
that was my christmas yeah it was one of
his yo you got an offer bro you got a
260 offer on it
you someone offered 18.18 it doesn't
belong to him
yeah i mean if a b wants to pull the
trigger you own this i mean
they were given to a b as a gift i mean
ian are going to split it
so you own the frenching fathers
50 50. you should sell that this is
valuable i will discuss with my partner
when we have a good job
it's already been minted it's a joke
it's this is great
this is a valuable nft
there's one place where i can't control
my emotions [ __ ] me
and that well nothing really dude what
does that mean
oh the pizza is here by the way bring it
just saying
ab come on now
i mean this is a nft that is satirizing
garyvee's
absolute
dog [ __ ] stupid
god i hate the v friends [ __ ]
so let's get the frenching fathers going
how much can we get for this 200 000
you got at least you got to pick a side
here a little bit like
literally 45 seconds what can i make
this this is it's already missing this
is out of his control this is it's
already minted oh my god
i have no association with this i don't
make money from it
i don't own it well then i mean leave
that that's abs decision he wants to he
wants to keep he wants to hang on to
these a b and e and a b and ian right
join me
no this is this is yours you want to
sell it sell it if you don't want to
sell it don't did he give it to you he
said 50 50. it was his gift wait wait
wait tell just tell me what you're
saying maybe he says a 50 50 we'll split
it
i guess now he's just having did he put
like a 50
smart contract i don't know how he did
it it's just a a buddy shake of the hand
what's happening ian you want 50 of this
i'm saying if he wants to sell it
then we can sell it but i'd have to i
thought i had to pay a gas fee to sell
it i just uploaded it so was it a gift
for a b or not yeah
well i uploaded a picture i didn't know
if we were actually selling it or if it
was just a gag
well i can't think it could go either
way but is it abs or not i mean if he
wants that's what i'm saying if he wants
to sell it
we can sell it
why do you keep saying we noticed that
he's if he wants to sell it what do you
mean
i would like to offer you i mean ian 50
for making it but why do you say we if
it's abs
i never gave him any like i'm freaking
out it's uploaded on my account so we'd
have are you freaking out love
because
it's so easy i see what's going on here
tell me what even has the thing but it's
promised to av
so if av wants to sell it he needs to
tell a b or [ __ ] he needs to tell ian
he's on ian's account what he said
crypto is so simple what don't you
understand
just
love is right it's not love is wrong
okay no i'm right and love is right and
love is wholesale and love loves love
conquers yeah love love is love
yes no wait can't you just send it to
abe's wallet
i i mean i guess theoretically what do
you mean you guess it's a game i don't
know how this works i just clicked
upload on a picture i thought i had to
pay a fee to make it a real nft i
thought that was where the whole like
ecological impact came i think you did
it says it was no i didn't i didn't even
link it to a wallet i just clicked
uploaded you can try right now if you
want and i said if that's if that's a
real entity we'll split it
yeah but i didn't think it was like a re
i don't know i don't know how it works i
don't know uh so interesting i think we
both kind of forgot about it
wow
so this is what it just looks like
chunks of chicken or something yeah this
is very very weird okay this isn't what
it's supposed to look like it looks like
just so first of all
let's look here
this does not look like kebab
i think everyone takes
me off so i can see love
yeah go ahead i'm following
kebab pizza
it's just a chunk of chicken i just
tried a piece
i'll try it right now
wait it is
it's good or no i mean it's not bad but
it don't taste like kebab
i thought it was supposed to be like
flaps of meat yeah that's exactly it's
like shavings yeah shavings
well try the sauce because that was what
you were right
this looks nothing like the swedish
sauce
[Music]
oh my god that smells super sour
so if you guys don't know love says his
favorite food is
pizza kebab yeah kebab pizza right which
is um
in sweden we do a lot of ginger
maybe just got a sandwich me down yeah
because it's there's pork on the uh the
kabob pizza so wait there's pork on this
i think this is pork yeah oh
which is quite unusual
i'll try the sauce now i dipped it right
here
wow it's not good it's not even good
no
you bro that's just like
basically that's just mayonnaise
yeah i think so
it's like tartar sauce and these people
claim to be swedish
hell no it's just tartar sauce
yeah
call those [ __ ] up right now
i won't have to talk with them
[Music]
i mean it's like tartar sauce it's not
bad but
do you think this is bacon because i
this literally looks like bacon
this right here
no no it's just chunks of pork no this
looks like a piece of bacon right it
looks like canadian bacon it looks like
bacon yeah we drove like a we drove like
two hours for this yet
now
this is a pizza i'll slam it either way
but it ain't a kebab pizza
damn
yeah cut this that's crazy we drove so
far for this specialty
but on the website i saw the photos and
it looked like yeah but that's not what
they gave us sam
did you buy the kebab plates too
the kebab
plate
no no i'm not okay
i love the way love says kebab
okay
babe okay baby it's you're my baby those
valentines
[Music]
well anyway so
let me just
if anyone has any leads on kebab pizza
in la
we're in california sam can drive
california california
i'm kidding
in los angeles please let me know dm me
it takes like 12 hours to drive to the
north of i was just kidding
i know a good place in sacramento oh
yeah
yeah
yeah but please let me know i deliver
kebab pizza
well we tried our best man i thought
i thought it would be i mean the pizza's
not bad right it's not bad oh he did the
pizza is fine
and i'm dipping it in mayonnaise which
is new thing for me
i mean that's what the sauce is
he has no pizza
it's basically just tartar sauce
i love pizza and i love people
pizza is very nutritious
yeah so i'm starting my kebab pizza
mission wait cam you got a cow zone
bring that out here oh did you get the
kebab kill
song yeah cam got the calzone cam is a
calzone boy yeah
we love that about him don't we cameron
is very nice
show me that
let me see what you got
cam got a kebab calzone
wow
and it's probably just the same chunks
of meat eh
okay fantastic
inside ooh manny's in the pizza
that's questionable folks
we question that don't we
we love to question the kebabs
well
speaking of trump
oh speaking of safe moon i guess we
should talk about that
so safe moon we've made fun of
safe moons going to the moon baby
it was like uh
what was it one dollar gets you like a
trillion safe moon or something just
bought 39 million shares of safe moon
and it was actually being promoted by a
bunch of huge personalities jake paul
soju boy nick carter
ben phillips little yachty
that's why everyone was so into the safe
moon
scam
well there's a lawsuit being filed did
you guys hear also the fbi setting up
their first crypto division
oh baby it's all about to go down
yeah that's pretty crazy i mean look you
got crypto the crypto arena
now the staple centers where the lakers
place now the crypto.com arena
you got these huge marketing campaigns
with matt diamond
what was it [ __ ] was that crypto.com
the
fortune favors the brave coin base or
was it coin no i don't think so i think
it was more scammy than coinbase
fortune favors the brave i think it was
crypto.com
dude crypto.com associated where are
they getting all this money from it's
crazy
well they have a huge amount of
investment from a lot of venture capital
things
which is
one of the things that
really over the last year has been
making me raise my eyebrow more and more
this whole crypto thing is the whole
promise of it is this like
revolution to stick it to the banks and
get away from traditional capital
finance you know it the whole thing sort
of was invented
prior to the 2008
collapse of the housing market but
that's really when it started to take
off
and um
more and more it's just becoming obvious
it's just being co-opted and and owned
by all the same vampires that control
the traditional capital so it's it just
doesn't all the big players
who are pushing it part of the same rich
[ __ ] right pushing whatever scheme they
are doing in traditional
currencies
you know
anyway the lawsuits are alleging that
celebrities lured in investors with me
misleading promotions
here's an example of people promoting
the coin this is real interesting
um
jake paul years ago i talked about doge
before elon
three months ago i talked about safe
moon
now i'm talking about yummy
it's clever he goes doge which is a real
thing now
by no
influence of
his safe moon is yummy
i'm gonna eat your ass
nick carter
oh no that yummy coin here's yummy by
the way
not doing so but jake paul's credibility
he knows what he's talking about you got
you got him that chewing is
yeah that's a lot
damn
now i'm talking about yummy
that was may 15th where does that sit on
the uh
on the rug
uh oh wouldn't you look at that that's a
perfect rug
that is a perfect rug
look at that it couldn't have been done
better
like a work of art look at that
gorgeous
more safe moon let's do safe moon
[Applause]
yeah it's right at the right there man
right before the dump
huge pump
oops
look up safe moon because he tweeted
about safe moon on march 27th
safe moon
well that's safe moon safe moon enu safe
moon version 2
safe moon nomiks
safe moon cash
i assume it's just this first one
yeah oh yeah no this is just today hold
on oh
there was a dump just today
not as bad as yummy
march 27.
march
27th
uh that was right
before it started
to go to the moon baby
i mean it's all relative like look at
how little all this is
actually valued at but
that chart doesn't look that bad where
they yeah
safe moon
safe mode
it didn't go to the moon
as promised
it didn't really bottom out still
oh almost back down to zero
so it's
there's just that it's all really that
one dude is still holding up yeah
i got 300 million safe moon
i'm holding out yeah
and then we've got uh
nick carter like the guy from
baxter then yeah dude it's time for
blast off
safe moon baby
hey i don't know but do you ever see um
promotions for like us dollars
no
that'd be weird right well there's like
bonds and stuff uh it's not quite the
same but it's hey guys now's a good time
to buy dollars or going to the moon
so it's weird that nick carter is uh
coming up in the story because just the
other day
uh ally
asked me if i remembered the
backstreet boys um
superhero comic
which apparently nick carter wrote at
like the height of their popularity and
stuff were you aware that they were
turned into a
team of superheroes no
i kind of want to get my hands on the
first edition of this the backstreet
project
now he's slinging crypto on twitter
what a fall what's his net worth nick
carter
i mean i'm sure he's still i mean his
crackhead brother's more famous than him
at this point
backstreet boys were missing we were
just watching
aaron carter box lamar odom that was
wild
yeah i don't know who set that up i know
uh net worth of 35 million dollars oh
god bless him
everybody's doing fine i mean those
backstreet boys royalties
of safe moves
that's actually impressive because
there's like five of them
you know
a little yachty
whatever who cares
little yatty i don't know who's ben
phillips
but he's being sued apparently whoa
youtuber
soulja boy
he just straight up tweets out
my public address to receive safe moon
what is he asking people to send him
safe mode he was
what
what
what the hell
yeah but where the missing is keemstar
who also promoted it i don't know why
he's not being sued
i have a theory
here's keemstar tweeted about safe moon
dan has a good theory well let's look at
it first
keemstar says safe moon march 31st
where's that on the graph april 16 we're
rich baby
truly believe in safe moon and not just
for a quick buck
i'm long people at safe moon are doing
so much good stuff
love the road map huge community already
feels like the start of something huge
in a world of a hundred thousand new
crypto coins this one sticks out
what you think
oh
one of two and also two of two i'm not a
financial advisor
i'm a youtuber yo you're in trouble that
crypto [ __ ]
i'm pretty sure this is how you know
it's an ad
because they make you write that
right
oh interesting it could be well that
goes against my theory and i might be
wrong but why would keemstar say he's
not a financial advisor like he gives a
[ __ ] what's your theory
i
i think he's just a dumbass that got
actually taken by safe moon i don't
think he's in on it i think he lost his
ass
coming with that heat so he's just an
idiot yeah who would pay him to promote
their product
i mean he gets 200 likes on his twitter
it's like it's not like he has engaged
that's pretty good that's a good theory
i think he i think he's being genuine
what he's saying he really believes
yo i'm sitting on 50 trillion safe boom
yep
if this just goes up one penny i'll be
richer than the united states government
why are you so cute when you talk [ __ ]
i'm sorry bob
i know i'm sorry
is it that bad
oh my god you guys just like all the
chats
the hero we don't what am i doing i'm
just trying i gotta eat
dude you don't get the struggle for
people like me
it so
even i probably shoot in the mic
sometimes but
to be honest it's really bad i'll be
honest all i could hear is zack chewing
you're right
i've never seen someone slap their lips
as much as this man yeah i don't want to
be rude but
it's pretty bad
i literally moved the mic
all the way away from me
you can still hear it unfortunately
you've been hearing it
yeah
yeah
there's like a civil war in the comments
some people want you to keep chewing too
quote unquote shut up the babies
well there was like a whole debate on
the subreddit where they're like i don't
know why everyone's complaining about
ethan chewing
and then there's apparently in the chat
everybody's losing their [ __ ] mind
and now everybody gets to eat pizza
about me
so what the [ __ ] kind of justice is this
and i'm just looking at everyone eating
their lunch and i'm supposed to sit here
and starve
if you take my pizza you don't get to
eat dan
you can take my pizza too i'm done
no
i'm stopping yourself put some tape over
your eyes
whatever you want then
i'm going to tape my mouth
anyway the lawsuit
says safeguard failed to deliver
promises with regards to its roadmap
that included the safe moon wallet an
nft platform
an nft platform as well as a crypto
exchange
what the [ __ ]
that's crazy that they didn't make a
crypto exchange
safe mode
um also in the news people are saying a
poll okay let's do a poll does my
chewing bother you
let's do it i feel like we've done this
before at great lengths who pushes the
mic away from me who's slaves and toils
i've got a newborn baby i don't sleep
yet here i am are the options just yes
does the chewing bother you yes or no
binary okay binary
bad
that's something i'm coming i'm playing
does ethan's strength bother you yes or
no drum roll please this poll confused
me i i answered no but i meant yes and
ed sheeran commented on my video
no way kill him the ed sheeran
i doubt it
i don't know how to look on tick-tock
[Music]
uh you guys got a result there the
nose have it
uh but i will say what's the percentage
i can't see it it's 69 no okay that's a
pretty that's a blowout
it's a blowout but here's the thing
that's a lot of people if 32 of our
audience it's a lot is like being driven
crazy that's that's a good chunk yeah if
it was like if it was like five to ten
percent be like
well thank you to the majority of you
who are have a heart that's 79
69.
uh to the other ones who are bothered by
it i won't eat because i know i know
what it's like to hear noises you don't
like especially when you're listening to
a podcast so
okay fine
anyway that being said the show is over
i'm gonna go eat
i'm just kidding
uh we are almost at two hours
well let's talk about the truth social
um well i kind of feel like maybe we
should
wait and see well because the i mean all
there is to really say right now is the
app is [ __ ]
crashing and burning wait this so true
so donald trump just launched his
twitter competitor truth hasn't he
already launched this like three times
i'm confused well there was like
god damn it yeah it's still this is this
is what happens when you're trying to
straight up down yeah
yeah i saw an image of someone who tried
to sign up at like 3am and they were in
a waiting line of like 100 000 people
and that's the thing even if so i've
been trying all morning to sign up and i
can't even get to the screen that you
sign up but even if you get through all
signing up does you is put you on a
waiting list to actually get can it be
that hard to get are they just getting
ddosed like
no i think that
the i mean i'm sure that they act
genuinely do have a huge influx of users
but also
um
it's kind of
it's this thing that like
all of these um conservative alt social
media platforms always have
horrible tech issues it's like they've
got the free memberships hosting option
yeah i don't know why it always happens
this way but like they can't [ __ ]
figure out how to build a website it's
it's strange that's what i'm saying like
they're like parlor and getter and uh
gab and like all of those frank speech
they're all getting hacked constantly
all like all of their user data getting
leaked it's like non-stop
i mean it happens to big i mean facebook
has had leaks and stuff too so but i
don't know so mark dice uh by the way
this i guess mark dice blocked me or
something because i can't open his
twitter oh no way it says unable to view
this tweet
for sure blocked you then mark dice he's
just another such a freak i hate that
guy
we'll pull it up yeah let me pull it up
and i uh i'm logged into the same
account so it's gonna be
blocked for me too unless he did delete
it
no he didn't erase it you're just
getting [ __ ] blocked
dice blocked yeah
it's the h3 podcast account why would he
block the h3 podcast
[Music]
what a baby
dice i've been beta testing beta
you beta tested i wouldn't do anything
with beta in the title never ever ever
do it
what a beta did
i've been a beta tester for trump's
truth social app follow me there once it
rolls out to the apple app store
tomorrow the media's gonna melt down
first thing monday morning i think the
website's gonna be the one that melts
down my friend
[Laughter]
cnn is gonna have some interns
join truth tomorrow to see what's going
on
uh okay sure definitely but until then
imagine how pissed they're gonna be
there they can't see what's what we're
saying right now or who's already joined
cnn sucks
what a hardcore cool dude
i just love that it's like
imagine how pissed they're gonna be when
they can't see what we're saying yeah we
can't nobody can see what you're saying
because your website's [ __ ] crashing
like how is
but even hypothetically if it was
working it's not like a behind a magic
curtain i mean it's a social media
platform yeah
it's very strange
wait he replied to himself so many times
oh yeah so he has replies off
and then he explains that he does that
to force the haters to quote tweet what
i said instead of being able to just
reply in the thread thus bringing your
message to an evil even wider audience
all their followers now you know you're
welcome 77 quote tweets
awesome dude
also i mean that's not
i mean if you follow somebody and they
reply to something you'll also see that
so that's not
a thing no he's just sensitive he
doesn't want people to say mean things
to him i can confirm alex jones will be
joining true soldier i told you media
meltdown is coming
that's all they care about is just a
meltdown
the media is not melting down because
trump made a twitter i
want more trump tweets i miss trump i
know i know bring it back man
but
here's some people that are on there
matt gates oh yeah majorie taylor green
huge paul gosar
huge uh madison cough
hawthorne cothorn huge and other members
of congress have already joined
um so i uh
went and found what they were uh posting
on there
and it's just as epic as you as you'd
imagine yo i'm about to have a meltdown
show me what they've been posting yeah
wendy rogers that one
crazy lady um welcome to all my friends
over on truth social this feels like a
2016 trump rally exciting do you know
about like the friends thing spelling it
like that this is like an epic fortune
wait it's like five years ago is this a
tweet
that's the thing
then she screenshots her account she has
four followers on there because again
nobody can get on there so they're all
just on twitter talking about how
awesome
truth social is the truth is epic it's
epic that's why i'm posting about it on
twitter i can't wait to get on truth
i've been trying
yep and i'm on truth baby
two followers truth socials going to the
moon they both have two she has two
accounts both with two followers
okay very cool
and then let's give you a big fat kiss
here i found a bunch of screenshots of
people that want to get on uh that can't
uh
i've been wait listed gotta be patient
just keep re-uploading oh that'll help
the website something went wrong over
and over getting an error message keep
trying i just got mine created keep
hitting the retry button it will go
through then you will be in the wait
list so just
you gotta you gotta get through the
first hurdle just to get on the waitlist
be patient it's slow
and then yeah i already showed you but
that's well that's what's happening on
the website right now so good stuff
maybe i reckon success just using some
of that uh
some of that billions of dollars
upgrading the hosting or something yeah
well
so i wanna
maybe there'll be more to report once i
can finally get on and start
experimenting that's exciting steps but
but how did how is he he's gonna be
competing with frank's speech i mean
they're gonna be dude mike lindell must
be so he's so what's going on at frank's
speech
you know he's still going strong i still
uh
still see frank's speech was supposed to
be the new twit right-wing twitter yes
which it still isn't a social media
platform which is odd
oh he's live right now
uh he's live 24 7.
i'm not kidding wow
he's
for like 16 hours
and then they're well
not only could these things escalate but
i think it's a near certainty given the
current imbalance of power between the
sides
because
dr
peter pray leadership and weakness by
the way
his last name is just a coincidence he's
not praying on our side and because
we're unprepared for cyber war or
conventional war in europe or nuclear
war i want to go back to the one thing
you said dr price you're saying
biden puts the sanctions on to is on to
uh excuse me russia as he's saying
tonight
russia has already said and has stated
before there would be women on my police
to pay on the us so what you're saying
is this would likely start with the new
way of warfare the new way of warfare
with the cyber attacks and blackouts so
you're saying putin is not going to let
us put a bunch of sanctions on him
without at least maybe engaging
high level political commentary to an
audience of two
michael
my pillows
will give you back paid for life
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] pillow dude
all right well we've got a lot more but
you know what it's two hours
we got much more to talk about we'll be
back on wednesday
right guys
that's right hell yeah we have another
show on wednesday
yeah are you serious
that's how it goes [ __ ] dude when does
alden ring come out
25th
25th that's uh
thursday
friday oh friday
we got to do a show on friday
well that means it comes out thursday
night probably you know what i mean
right
um right i think we can beat it before
we have to start the show on friday
someone will say
what are the chances of us being on time
on friday with that coming out thursday
night what's the chance of us being on
time any day right so let's cut that in
half
whatever those chances are
the same as always
i guess
let me just read off some of these
donors real quick before we
go uh youtube added a cool feature where
you can actually like
see them
in a way that isn't super roundabout so
that's nice let me open the stream i can
see what you're talking about
uh
let's see uh carla just celebrating that
she's been a member for 12 months a
whole year
[ __ ] yeah carla
yeah
we love that carla don't we
uh you guys should put a sticker of uh
animated and an animated sticker
on theodore instead of the blur i think
is what this is saying what does that
mean
instead of blurring the stickers look
weird
it doesn't quite cover and i don't know
it's a weird thing
uh
somebody made a youtube video
confronting the public if kavkav and
harvey look alike for the movement the
data is compelling all right
we'll check that out yeah lovely k-ray
uh where i come from swedish pizza is
another name for female anatomy
is that true a swedish pizza i don't
know
i know if
wait what
for a female private part
we heard that
never heard them
i know fifa in italian is
[ __ ]
uh anime versus hip-hop donated 20 bucks
and said ethan not sleeping is the
funniest thing that happened to this
show don't waste that man's sleep and
how is that funny
i think
it's more so what it has done to your uh
personality
you're
we're getting
sleep deprived ethan over here i saw a
thread where people were saying the show
sucks and it's not funny and people were
arguing did you see that [ __ ] those
people dude but it's like dude i'm
literally
i sh i shouldn't even be here okay
you guys are a bunch please don't stop
that i really feel like you're about to
drop down this thing is fragile man i'm
watching from the side and it looks like
it's about to slip
okay go ahead keep keep reading
lawsuits going to the moon baby uh yeah
uh
keemstar promoted safe mode apparently
thank you for donating for that as you
saw we we did uh we did touch on that uh
let the king eat a chew zone the chewing
is not that bad i didn't even notice
until dan mentioned it i can't see i
listened to the show with airpod pros
and never hear the chewing
okay so you don't have the issue that's
fine all right great for you
i'm envious
nothing makes me trip uh trust a crypto
coin more than when a d-list celebrity
promotes it like the diarrhea skinny tea
yeah that's that's a good point
uh somebody donated 10 bucks and let
them eat wow thank you
uh the worst part is that pizza isn't
even halal so true
uh just true away from the mic
revolutionary idea i know he was trying
he was trying to do that
i'm getting i'm in the section where all
of them are about the chewing so forgive
me let me keep scrolling here uh
ethan learn how to use a napkin bro
i don't have [ __ ] on my face
what is what is the nap the napkin is
going to make more noise that's true you
want to hear the ruffling do you think i
have [ __ ] on my face
no go off king
thank you
uh we'd love to see bts of zach's
soundbite set up i believe that is in
one of the bts yes so if you're a member
you can go back into the backlog i don't
know that one was actually prior to
being members only that was bts number
three on the highlights channel look at
that go on the highlights channel bts
number three so look into my world it'll
look pretty cool yeah into the wild wild
world
in my world oh hey partner um by the way
there is a new bts up for members thank
you to members
uh thank you to everyone who's staying
as who's staying a member i understand
we're not putting content out early
right now because everything's live for
the sake of ease of my life for now
won't be like that forever but for the
next few couple months um
uh but that being said we are still
providing the bts thank you a b
and there's a new one up every week
so go enjoy that
you didn't watch it did you
not this week's okay good
probably don't want to watch that what
does that mean just don't watch it don't
worry about it don't worry about it
what's in the face
come on no we did it it was a crew q a
and so you know yeah
what does that mean it took out any
mention of you forget about it
didn't make the final cut what is this
loose lips
sleep with the fishes
all right uh
somebody um long-time member said uh
cryptocurrency is not a ponzi scheme
okay well fair enough right now settle
that's a settled issue
um
16 months 16 months a member 19 months
money
i don't even think we
had memberships that long
well we it was available but like
totally right
or anything well thank you
19 months that's amazing going on two
years legend
uh
can you tell ethan to take me to the
lake please i'm gonna take you out the
lake okay
you got two good eyes that's two you
don't need two wives okay
you don't need two kidneys you know what
i'm saying
no no
i'm gonna take you out the link
i'll show you the meaning of family 16
months
caleb [ __ ] all these people i haven't
eaten
i come before you with a slice of pizza
boy
and the
chewing is too much for you
come on
i delivered food to ryan cavanaugh the
other day and he was wearing one of the
worst outfits i have ever seen
if that's true
i mean
more info well not surprising
i mean we have no way to verify that i
guess
i hope that's true
oh man
how's the website doing ryan kavanagh
google ryan kavanagh oh you know what i
want to do someday i think it's so funny
i want to read his wikipedia page since
he started the war with the wiki mods
maybe i'll do that on ethan klein
just read the whole thing no i read it
it's every line is just like
the man cannot get through a single
sentence now and it's just oozing with
controversy like
go let's see early life okay
like how's there gonna be a problem with
a guy's early life right
ryan cavanaugh was born in l.a raised in
brentwood
uh his mother was a broker his dad was a
dentist
um
kavanaugh attended uc santa barbara and
ucla but dropped out
in 1996 in 2012 kavanaugh threatened the
new york times with legal action
for its reporting on him including its
report that he dropped out of university
kavanaugh claimed to have officially
graduated from ucla but and and he
enrolled in the phd program at usc but
the new yorker stood by its reporting
that he's a [ __ ] dropout loser
subsequent sources report kavanaugh
finished his
degree uh
the wall street journal reported that
there was no record of him to ever
taking classes at usc so like even in
his early life
it's like this guy lied about his
education which is just weird and
pathetic first-hand experience
it's just oozing it's just it's so fat
that and then did we read this already
the philanthropy part i believe i i
think so yeah
did it's
awesome anyway the whole thing is just
like poetic so i want to read the whole
thing it's a beautiful thing
do we got a capcaf tweet
yeah so he's linking to another like a
wikipedia on his twitter page
and someone on reddit pointed out that
even on that reddit
it's like talking [ __ ] on him wait what
the [ __ ] is golden.com goldonshower.com
but he thought he bypassed the [ __ ] talk
on that like a normal wikipedia this one
also has it he's just so bro just have a
linkedin why do you need to have on
another website nobody goes to
golden.com
well he's trying to [ __ ] seo it
so let's see when he writes his self
let's see what he says
early life okay so we can compare here
let's see he wants blah blah blah his
dad is a dentist blah blah so far it's
exactly the same
his dad is a surgeon a founder of this
company blah blah blah blah
he became one of the largest biotech ipo
of 2014. oh daddy's rich as [ __ ] and was
later
purchased by
some company for nine billion holy [ __ ]
yeah this is the thing i i've
i've brought up several times that he
comes from money and
um
in most sources it always just kind of
describes his dad as a dentist but like
i think he was a dentist but he also
was like
a serial entrepreneur that owned a ton
of businesses around l.a
tell me if you think ryan wrote this
part
listen this
from a young age
kavanaugh had been influenced by his
father's entrepreneurial bent
he also had a knack for working numbers
uh all of a sudden it goes from
wikipedia
style writing to autobiography
he the man had a knack for working
numbers
he had been influenced by his father's
entrepreneurial bet
he was a great guy that ryan kavanagh
with a good clean heart
never a scammer wouldn't scan wouldn't
cross anybody ever
let's see what he says about relativity
of the company he bankrupted
it's a lot he has a lot to say about it
under kavanaugh's leadership
relativity built a powerhouse
television company
did you [ __ ]
bankrupted your company dude
under let's see if he says under ryan's
leadership
relatively got bankrupted let's see
let's see how's he spin this
in 2015
relativity
filed for bankruptcy
shortly thereafter
kavanaugh partnered
kavanaugh's partner joe nicholas
purchased back the company oh it's all
good nothing went wrong
in 2018 kavanaugh sold relativity to
ultra v holdings
but remained a consultant with an
incentive package that includes 10
equity
and any value above 150 million
today relativity continues to be a mini
major studio listen to how he's tried to
spin this
[ __ ] so nice
such a nice ending to the story
[Music]
this is great
so
there at the top there's a tab called
issues
oh really go to true to contribution
by ryan kavanagh yeah
there's a user wait there's a user named
ryan cavanaugh who's editing this page
and click that and go to that link
dude
nine hours ago
because i told you that there was bad
stuff on here but i didn't find them now
it's because he's [ __ ] removing it
all
you are such an idiot dude you're
editing it under your own name and
you're so active i can see you were on
here eight hours ago you loser
here let's see he removed and it's not
harvey weinstein fair
that's true
as a co-founder he spearheaded the
acquisition of triller so he removed all
this is that what it say
i don't know for sure but that is what
it looks like
yeah if it's red yeah
he removed this and added this oh juicy
if i don't say so myself
i've got a lot to say about myself
i've got a lot to add
this screenshot is my
personal favorite
he added something very funny
he added here
yeah that that he's not
oh he added that
allegedly wait you changed the color
no that's on another tab if you back up
it's this is ruined red
it says it's not that means it was now
removed no he removed it he removed it
yeah but he if you go go back to his
profile
yeah he made this edit before
no no shot
yeah he added it wait let me just link
it to you he added or you removed it
unless it's at the bottom before though
here click that
okay
golden shower.com
now see this is a different account dude
this is caleb johnston yeah shout out to
caitlyn johnson yeah
okay
yeah so caleb that's funny but ryan's in
there cleaning up his own golden article
that's awesome he's been i love that
he's in there why would you use your own
name don't you understand you're not
supposed to edit your own [ __ ]
wikipedia page
it's probably not
it's not wikipedia it's golden they
probably don't give a [ __ ]
i bet what even is this i'm sh i bet
they do they probably have some rules of
conduct maybe we should report his
account
yeah you shouldn't be working
but he shouldn't be editing his own page
i'm assuming could someone look up at
the faq on golden all right let's look
at the terms of service if there's rules
of engagement for editors on this
so he let's see
he removed this
oh ryan kevin has been accused by his
ex-partner running a ponzi scheme this
topic has been covered by variety and is
publicly available to read on this
website and he he right so he removed
that
he also removed over the years have been
many people have seen harvey once here
on the street mistaking them for ryan
kavanagh for this reason a publicly
funded website has been created
uh to tell the difference
it does right kevin look like harvey
wants to see he removed that
is it really his spot to be editing his
own page you guys
relatively purchase overture i don't
know why i removed that one
i love that he added all this fluff
there we go
articles about yourself
inaccuracies or obvious errors should be
quickly fixed by anyone including the
subject of the biography okay
additional concerns about tone balance
or inclusion of specific information can
be brought to the attention of support
oh well we should probably
who can help fix the material to align
with golden's policies
subjects
who have legal or serious concerns about
material so it seems like they're
they're they're not as
neutral as doesn't sound like it
although i wonder if
you know if somebody was to reach out to
support at golden.com
[Music]
and just make them aware of the fact
that ryan kavanagh was
heavily heavily editing in a biased
manner his own um well it says
additional concerns about tone balance
or inclusion
right so i mean clearly there are some
issues at hand about balance
yeah
i just think it's a it's just how can
you be balanced about yourself
[Music]
right and i mean i saw certain things in
there uh that were removed that didn't i
mean seemed
historically accurate like the fact that
variety published an article about how
his ex partner accused him of running
that's not an inaccuracy right like that
did happen the article was published
right the ponzi scheme i don't know i
mean what the hell do i know about it
yeah yeah just saying the article was
published they made it public
later issued a
retraction a retraction
well they didn't retract it
uh his partner retracted it right and
they updated the article correct
i don't know nothing about nobody i got
one eye i don't see nothing
okay wait now this is interesting here
this might be relevant to golden's rules
it says
do not use golden for advertising seo of
your product
well he's not selling a product we are
happy for products companies and servers
to be mapped out on golden
company and product website should only
be used on the topic page for the entity
and not add to other comp i mean i i
feel like he's not breaking that rule is
he any compromising any compromising of
pages by over seo stuffing result in
account ban
i feel like he doesn't do that does he
i mean the whole point of this is for
seo i don't know because he's not an
actual product but he said they don't
say you call the product they say you
can't i don't say you can't seo they
just say you can't like
stuff your [ __ ] into other articles
how do you interpret that love you're
the expert
yeah well it seems to
prevent people from promoting their own
product
is ryan kevin a product probably not no
i think it's just to prevent you from
going to like target paige and being
like target sells the
ryan kavanagh biography
i am not harvey weinstein
that's not a real book
just a joke so why did he remove that
would that not
make it make you believe the contrary
i don't know
because that was
making making stuff clear now i'm not
sure anymore i'm not sure about anything
it also has another uh
term service about uh neutral point of
view
okay well that's important
he's probably in violation of that eh
yeah so he's opening issues about
himself on his own page about neutrality
yeah
that i find odd
extremely odd
yeah that's fun shout out to golden
yeah i love bro what is he doing he's
tweeting this [ __ ] out is this a seo
thing too long to read but i imagine
this one is kinder if you really want to
get under the foot soldier skin you
gotta get to the top of wiki feet
from dp
holy [ __ ] that's such a good name
by the way we haven't thanked throats or
we haven't not thinked because obviously
listen he does what he does
but i will say if you go to
ashtrays3shop.com
we haven't talked about this i love
throst shirt
enough
and also we haven't talked about ryan
going after you love
right what what what's that [ __ ]
i don't know the the other month or i
guess it's a month ago at this time
i woke up
with a
dm from ryan kavanagh first of all
on
linkedin
who that was kind of omnius i don't have
a screenshot what did he say he said
nice to finally meet you like he thinks
you're thrust essentially yeah that's
because that's what he said to the
person in the shrek forum right right
africa nice to finally meet you in the
shrek forum and the message honestly
scared me a little bit it sounded very
very scary because very omnius well like
also stalkery oh yeah extremely stalkery
like no one knows my last name out there
i've pers i've kept it secret for a
reason
but somehow rank haven't i found it out
i have no clue how oh really yeah that
is quite ominous right and uh if you
want to talk about the website thing too
you want to do that sure yeah well he
sent a
correct me if i'm wrong but what i
believe is a like a copyright claim on
the url of the website so he's claiming
copyright for the
his name essentially
i think that does harvey weinstein look
like frank cavanaugh ryan kavanaugh the
part that's how i understood it i don't
know for sure wait is that not what
they're suing us for is this a different
thing
well he sent a complaint for the website
domain
yeah that's what we're we're doing yeah
that one you already uh talked about no
we didn't talk about the complaint he
sent to me
because did you send that to the lawyers
yeah okay good we're fighting a huge
legal battle over the website by the way
yeah i'm spending tens of thousands of
dollars to keep that website up hope you
guys know yeah since i uh easily tens of
thousands yes since i'm hosting the
website i got involved in that pretty
harsh so he's sending he's sending [ __ ]
home to my parents
oh for real yeah because you're it loves
an agent of of our company obviously so
we're paying all the legal fees and
stuff but his name is was on the
registration of the website right so
wait he's what are your parents getting
like just
notices of
legal actions against the website
and like like 30 pages of
evidence towards me and my social with
with screenshots of my social media [ __ ]
that's in the complaint that where my
twitter and my instagram
and like screencaps of my face and super
wear [ __ ] dude he did deep ops on you
yeah and like he he he's sharing
all my stuff online is on a 40-page
document that he sent home to me
he's trying to scare you yeah
essentially yeah it's pretty funny
i wonder if we could put it on the
website
oh you don't want all that stuff out
there yeah yeah i don't want to leak my
my [ __ ] you know
ryan does he yeah he found everything i
have
he's probably paid a lot of money for
someone to like do crazy
ops on you i think we have a redacted
version of the whole thing somewhere we
prepared something but i'm not sure
where if we have that already a while
back yeah
yeah pretty crazy right this guy's a
absolute psycho maniac it's just a silly
website ryan you know it's a public
service man why you got to try to like
scare my dude
yeah i asked if we could like do
anything about it but i guess not
it's just
i'm not to worry about it personally i
know
i know i got the support and everything
so well if he's gonna kill anyone it'll
be me don't worry i'm right
i just think it's funny
i think it's
oh and he followed me on twitter too so
i can reply to all his stuff
oh he followed you yeah
you should dm him what's up no don't
don't well i heard this i responded to
him on linkedin
um what did you say just
ask i asked
how what i could help him with what can
i help you with yeah you always you're
dick mangled like harvey's and so
did he respond to you no he did it show
red
no he hasn't read it i don't think he
uses linkedin that often so he's just
trying to scare you oh for sure i know
who you are dude
yeah
yeah i mean he sent me that threatening
dm on instagram
yeah i mean these are some [ __ ] gross
tactics
that if we were like nobodies
for example er if if uh
you know if we were nobodies we had no
resources no lawyers that would have
scared me if i had no resources
absolutely yeah
well it does and it works for him yeah
it's probably worked for him for a long
time up until now
oh here here's the copy of it this is so
creepy his linkedin message said hi love
nice to finally meet in parentheses find
you
right
wow
what [ __ ] creep
yeah i mean he's a big time hollywood
producer he's used to intimidating and
silencing people it's kind of part of
their job at this point and uh well
guess what ryan eat my dick it's not
gonna work
i will never back down from you ever
oh
the intimidation tactics won't work
i thought you said your dick doesn't
work i said my dick doesn't work he said
suck my dick i say drink my dick right
it doesn't work
i said i'll never back down from you
ever
so eat my dick it doesn't work
you proved it interesting
all right by the way sea change is the
company he's merging with
or they're trying to merge with i don't
know if there's any news with that
oh i've seen
but
uh trying to merge with them or whatever
right yeah they're crushing it reversed
murder
there was a huge spike when they
announced it
and uh they're back down in the [ __ ]
damn
yeah down to a dollar per share guys
should it
should have shorted them i knew better
it's still time there's still there's
still places to drop
i'm telling you
short trailer
yeah what the [ __ ] is all this cam
cam you have a job to do
tweeting during the show bad boy hashtag
bad boy what the hell dude who the [ __ ]
do you think you are
anyway i love throws shout outs to uh
the cav cav he's still crushing it
shout out to brad the bull who's giving
it to his wife good enough where
she still you know lets him see the kids
so that's nice
all right i gotta eat some pizza you
guys
thanks for watching see you on wednesday
see you then
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]